bonjour bienvenue dans les traits
élégants studio radio de radio canada à
washington
on est ici pas très loin de la très
jolie maison blanche et pour savoir qui
va déménager là en janvier
il ya un chiffre que vous devez retenir
270 270 c'est le nombre de grands
électeurs kerry fenton ou dans notre hub
a besoin de remporter son besoin de
remporter leur vote
pour être élue au collège électoral donc
non les américains les électeurs
américains votent pas directement pour
leur président eelv ont coché un choix
la présidence mais ça va influencer
dicté le choix des grands électeurs qui
représente leur état donc au total 538
grands électeurs qui forment collège
électoral pour l'emporter donc ça prend
la moitié de ces votes + 1 270 au
minimum d etat plus populeux comme la
californie en 55 votes au collège
électoral ce qui veut dire qu'on
remporte la californie remportent
beaucoup de vote des états où il ya
moins de gens qui y habitent comme le
wyoming on a seulement trois votes au
collège électoral
ces votes ce poids au collège électoral
ça représente le poids de l'état dans la
population c'est arrivé quatre fois
seulement dans l'histoire américaine
qu'une personne a été élu à la
présidence sans en plus avoir la
majorité au vote populaire donc
normalement la majorité d'américains va
choisir un des deux candidats et ça va
se refléter aussi au collège électoral
c'est possible qu'il y ait égalité c'est
très rare encore une fois 269 de chaque
côté à ce moment là ça serait la chambre
des représentants qui décideraient les
grands électeurs vont se rencontrer en
décembre environ un mois après le vote
de novembre
mais pour bien les américains hillary
clinton ou dans notre chambre seront
véritablement choisi le 8 novembre